[Music]
hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about the most controversial theory
knowledge immigrants the theory goes
that tyrion is not timing lannister son
but that is actually the son of the Mad
King Aerys the second Targaryen this
would mean that Aaron is Dana's her
brother and Justin's uncle the theory
not only helps to explain why timing I
really despise his youngest son so much
but also by the journals like him for
years any fan brave enough to flow this
game turns theory has been left at
whatever the time this theory looks more
and more credible there's actually a ton
of hints and clues supporting this
theory in both the books in the show
series so let's just get right into it
the first part of this puzzle is
relationship between Joanna Lannister
Tina's mother and there's the second met
King Targaryen several references in the
book suggests that Mad King Aerys
Daenerys is evil father had more than a
flirtation with unions mother Johanna
in fact there's evidence to support the
idea they were either lovers in the time
before she maritime minister during her
wedding night to type in or anytime
immediately after it's even been
suggested that Ivan hated Tyrion anxious
because he was a dwarf or because his
birth resulted in Joanna's death but
because he knew Tyrion was not his own
child in A Song of Ice and Fire series
it said that even whilst I mean in
journal intermarried era so still
infatuated with her in reference to
Draenor he drunkenly joked about I was a
pity the tradition of the first night
which allow the king to sleep with new
Brides was banned there's no reading A
Dance with Dragons upon their wedding
night
Eris took certain unwanted liberties
during her bedding ceremony
much the time in this pleasure bars the
cell Mattel's then in a dance with
dragons that her father Aerys wanted to
sleep with Joanna Lannister on wedding
night to Taemin Prince Aerys as a youth
he was taken with a certain lady of
Casterly Rock a cousin of timing
Lannister when she and time invade your
father drank too much wine at the
wedding feast and was heard to say that
it was a great pity that Lords right to
the first Knight had been abolished a
jerk and Jake know more about timing
Lannister was not a man to forget such
words or the deliberate days your father
took during the wedding
although there's no word that those
bearing liberties were it's pretty clear
that Eris lusted after Johanna there was
even a rumor in Westeros that Joanna had
been near his mistress when she was
younger perhaps even losing her
Maidenhead to him before she was
dismissed as a lady in waiting by the
future Queen Princess Royal a Targaryen
with no reason that were given still the
seeds were planted that Terrace was more
fond of Joanna demos acceptable it is
possible that at some point heirs got is
very embedded Joanna Lannister where
blackmail or otherwise my tieran have
been the result of that Union da+ Jake
will stay timing makes a lot of sense
one of the biggest critics of this
theory is that the timing of joy Navi
Terrace does not match Victorians
conception after Joanna was dismissed by
Queen rhaella she was said to have
rarely visited King's Landing afterwards
and lived their days at Casterly Rock
but George are morons recent will cover
all of Ice and Fire makes a distinct
point of mentioning the Jaina attended
University tourney in King's Landing in
272 AC which was held to celebrate King
Eris's 10th year in the throne during
this tournament we also learned King
Aerys insulted China by asking her in
nursing her children held rowing her
breasts the next day type in who was
also present at the tourney tried to
resign as the hand of the king but King
Gary's refused him perhaps diving try to
resign because of Eris's insult to his
wife or perhaps it was because something
much more serious had occurred less than
a year later Joanna died giving birth to
Tyrion in 273 I see sometimes point out
errors resulting time his wife would be
a weak reason to cause diving out of all
people from wanting to resign from such
a powerful position and claim that it's
very likely that something else happened
something that remains unknown to all
except for the Mad King journey and
timing according to those who knew
type-in and Johanna well the only time
time and smiled was venturing I was
present and then Joanna died giving
birth to Tyrion the best part of time in
died with her in spite of Jenna's death
if diamonds love for her was so great
why did he hate Irian his eldest son
Jamie is a member of the Kingsguard and
cannot marry
meaning the Tyrion is the only one who
can legitimately carry on tiemens branch
of House Lannister timing continually
refuses to consider Tyrion is heir which
seems odd given his focus on family and
legacy in a storm of sorts as valence
shove serious tiny rebukes Tyrion by
telling him
men's loves give you the right to bear
my name and display my colors since I
cannot prove that you're not mine to
teach me humility the gods have
condemned me to watch you waddle about
wearing that proud lion that was my
father's sigil and his father's before
him but the inner God's nor men shall
compel me to turn Casterly Rock into
your house
Tywin wants to be respected and doesn't
think having a dwarf first son is
respectable
he's also nursing an irrational grudge
against Tyrion for killing his mother in
childhood but this could also be an
acknowledgment by timing that Tyrion is
not in fact his son in addition to
type-ins insinuation that Tyrion is not
his son he continually lobs insults at
him your new mate devious disobedient
spiteful little creature for family lust
and low cunning says type-in to Tyrion
they'll mate crack is
especially noteworthy on the surface
it's another insult about Tyrion being a
dwarf but it could also be an
insinuation that you know the product of
unwanted relationship between heiress
and Joanna literally he was made in the
wrong way since their hands Burt
resulted in Joanna's death Timon hates
him even more time is resentment to
Tyrion similar to Catelyn Stark's
feelings towards Jon Snow Catholic Harry
Jon Snow because he was a living proof
that her husband was with another woman
the timing hey Tyrion because he was a
reminder that his beloved wife had been
with another man perhaps after all time
is dying words are denial the Tyrion is
his son Tyrion's appearance might even
support diamonds claim Turner looks more
like a Targaryen than a Lannister
the Targaryen star famed for their civil
hair and purple eyes in the book series
hair is described as a mixture of pale
blonde hair that's almost white it's
more dirty blonde in the show Jenna
Stone described Syrian in-game journal
says having a mixture of hair so blond
it seemed white and black hair his white
blond hair sounds a lot more like a
silver hair of the Targaryen Sten the
golden yellow locks of his Lannister
siblings his eyes are also mismatched
one green and the other black Tyrians
appearance contrasts with that of Jaime
and Cersei who L classic Lannister looks
green eyes and golden blond hair
siblings obviously don't always look
alike but Joanna and timing were first
cousins so have the tyrion end up with
the black eye and whitish air while
having green eyes is a Lannister trade
there was a character named shear sister
in Song of Ice and Fire history who was
the best heard of a Targaryen king and
had two different colored eyes just like
Tyrion it could suggest duality of his
parentage as well since you know the
seed is strong and appearance is a major
clue for parenting Martin series Tyrians
image should not be overlooked
matter of fact that goes hand in heavy
time is claimed of Tyrion not being his
son historians fascination with dragons
and Dragons not burning him alive and he
approach them like many other Targaryen
stearin also has a fan idea for firing
dragons which is mentioned throughout
the books on the show especially if note
is a conversation with John in the Game
of Thrones Tyrion says when I was your
age I used to dream of having a dragon
on my own
oh yes even stunt a twisted ugly little
boy can look down over the world when
he's sitting in the Dragons back I used
to start fires in the bowels of Casterly
Rock and stare at the flames for hours
pretending they were dragon fire
sometimes I would imagine my father
burning at other times my sister don't
look at me that way bastard I know your
secret
you joined the same kind of dreams
during a dance with Dragons Tyrion
crosses paths to the red priests McCory
like Milla Sanjay mokoro can't see the
future in the flames although his
predictions are markedly more accurate
than hers
he tells Tyrion he sees dragons old and
young true and false bright and dark and
do a small man with a big shadow
snarling in the midst of it all the
dragon is the sigil of House Targaryen
what's most interesting here is that
McCrory speaking only of dragons and
associates Tyrion with them will tario
never fulfill his dream of riding a
dragon it said the general server
selected about who they allow to ride
him and having Valyrian blood may be a
factor ray Callum is Aaron are
especially friendly material which in
this theory is because he has a I gave
me a lineage and therefore a blood of
old Valyria blood of the dragon Tyrion
being heir says bastard would that
another level of explanation as to why
he would put Jamie on his Kingsguard the
lynnster lands title stem valve would
then fall to his bastard in addition
this might be the same reason why time
he rejects Tyrion as his heir so Jaime
became a knight of Kingsguard he was
never allowed to marry only endure for
children for the rest of his life Tyrion
should have become timing's next
rightful heir to the Lannister lanes but
tyvan outright refused him if a + J
equals T sure it could be an explanation
for why timing refused to give to your
Lannister Casterly Rock and all the
other rights that go with it
so basically Aris not only took away
time in so near by making Jaime a knight
of the Kingsguard but made it because
his bastard son was the only other heir
to Casterly Rock another clue supporting
a theory of Tyrion having a blood of the
Dragon will be his mother's death
Durin's mother died during childbirth
just like Jon Snow's and the nurses
matters both diamond and Cersei
constantly remind Tyrion that his reason
Joanna died while giving birth to him
they call names like murderer and
monster but coincidentally or not so
coincidentally he measures trade with -
our main characters in the series
Daenerys and Jon Snow Daenerys Targaryen
was born during a storm on Dragonstone
and her mother Iowa died following
complications from her birth Jon Snow is
also Targaryen and his mother Lyanna
Stark died during a childbirth at the
Tower of joy although it's not necessary
for mother to die to give birth to a
Targaryen this coincidence cements the
three main characters together and could
be a major clue that they may be tied to
one another as ever great theory that
came true throughout the show this
theory has been foreshadowed heavily as
well in the very first episode of the
series Tyrion says to John all dwarves
are bastards in their father's eyes and
this theory gives the squad a whole new
meaning in the stereotype in Trinity
Relic bastard because he released one in
the season 3 premiere tyrannous Tywin
Mike is not being made
to the lane sir home of Casterly Rock
Tiger replies with men's laws give you
the right to bear my name and display my
colors since I cannot prove that you're
not mine
well having could be coming solely from
place the resentment the line seems to
indicate that timing is not here Ian's
father and he is very well aware it yet
again Davin might have given another
clue about here is real lineage in the
season 3 finale time says he wanted to
John Tyrion after he was born since he
was at work and Joanna died in
childbirth instead I let you live and
brought you up as my son he says Davin
does call Tyrion Elena stirring the
moment but if Tyrion was his biological
son why will he feel need to say I
brought you up as my son in the season 4
finale with the help of his head brother
Jaime Tyrion escapes his fate of
execution that his father had ordered
after Tyrion discover Shane his father's
bed he finds dive in a toilet and shoots
him at crossbow afterward Taemin states
you're not son of mine tiller replies I
am your son I've always been your son
and shoots him dead again is this just
ray Jed who Tyrion is or is there
something more at play in the fifth
episode of the fifth season while
traveling near Valyria Joris captive
Tyrion cause the history of the phone
study which was the ancestral home of
the Targaryen I suppose this is it then
this is what remains
Tyrion says right before dragon flies
overhead this moment seemingly occurs
just to set up the first time Tyrion
sees the dragon but perhaps it was also
for sharing that both Geoghan and Tyrion
are remnants of the balunians finally
the second episode of the sixth season
gave the biggest boost to the Tyrion
Targaryen theory he's successful in
shackled any dragons really miss Aryan
without getting burnt alive which
definitely seemed like a clue about
Tyrion to paternity it's not anyone that
can walk away from a dragon unscathed
in a Storm of Swords anything's to
herself the dragon has three heads there
are two men in the world who I can trust
if I can find them I will not be alone
then we'll be three against the world
like Aegon and his sisters if John is
the second head of the dragon COO Tyrion
be deterred another interesting parallel
is that if Tyrion is a Targaryen this
means he and Jamie each killed the
others father a plus J equals T and as
always I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see you in the next one peace
[Music]